you took Stevie Wonder for a ride in  your Tesla yes that's true yes that  story so we were in front of CAA one day  and got big ancient agency agency huge  yeah and so the AH Stevie's uh his  handler comes up and said hey Stevie  loves his car he wants to you know get  him I was interested in that Tesla ya  know yet he hadn't seen it he wasn't he  wanted this cars no pun intended  nobody tell funny in the car he had not  been in this yeah right so he gets in  see what is in he's like you know any of  you met him if you must have yeah I've  never met him so he's saying he's kind  of doing this you know he's touching it  like oh man it's cars amazing so I was  like it's really fast he was like let's  drive like uh so we went around the  block whoa he was like ah this is so  cool I you should let me drive hey  Stevie Stevie the cars electric not  magic  [Laughter]  you